alors la France qui a voté pour la
France on va revenir bien sûr sur la
prestation de la France la France les
Suédois ils ont mis 10 points Arméniens
7 points finlandais 7 points tituanien 6
points 6 points les Danois 5 points les
Irlandais 5 points les Espagnols 4
points les cernes 3 points les
Néerlandais 1 point euh les Belges et le
public c'est les Arméniens qui ont voté
pour nous 10 points norvégien 8 points
islandais 4 points et ensuite la cata la
Catala cata la caca la Catala
catastrophe euh la France pour qui on a
voté nous la France on a donné 8 points
pour la Finlande 10 points pour
l'Autriche et 12 points pour Israël
les chéris donc au moment de l'annonce
des points de la France le public
français a forcément été déçu puisque en
fait maintenant ça y a les points et
ensuite il y a les points du public et
ça peut faire tout basculer donc ça n'a
rien fait basculer du tout et la Zara a
forcément été très très déçu le problème
c'est qu'elle l'a fait savoir en direct
d'une manière d'une manière assez
directe vous allez voir les images alors
que beaucoup vont un doigt d'honneur
elle nique ce ne serait un geste qui dit
tant pis je m'en moque on regarde et on
en parle bien entendu bon voilà c'est
voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc c'est ce qu'on appelle le double
doigts
déjà
la France mérite pas ce genre de geste
déjà et même même si elle n'a eu que 50
points du public ne pas gagner à
l'Eurovision c'est pas grave parce que
ça fait ça porte toujours quelque chose
Amir a fait une grande carrière il est
au sixième donc ça ne change rien il
peut y avoir qu'un gagnant d'accord mais
ça non quoi ce genre de colère comme ça
je ça m'a choqué vraiment j'ai jamais vu
en fait ça alors c'est ce qu'on appelle
alors
la première chose c'est que moi je pense
que c'est quelqu'un enfin je la connais
un petit peu c'est quelqu'un de sanguin
et de très sensible et c'était une façon
de réagir comme ça spontané et pour moi
pour dédramatiser un peu la situation je
pars du principe que c'est l'Eurovision
et j'ai déjà vu des hommes politiques
comme Éric Zemmour ou Dupond-Moretti
faire des doigts ce qui me choque mille
fois plus que dans un contexte de
révision ou un petit doigt se balade
c'est pas classe je suis d'accord mais
de là est-ce que ça soit choqué je
regarde un peu les commentaires sur les
réseaux sociaux les gens ont l'air aussi
de s'en amuser donc ça me trauma c'est
ça personnellement moi moi aussi voilà
elle a son caractère voilà ce gazon ça
va devenir elle a son caractère après
Siri voilà je comprends que Marie soit
choqué aussi voilà alors elle
immédiatement après la fin de la
cérémonie à la tenue à s'expliquer pour
elle il ne s'agit absolument pas d'un
doigt d'honneur regarde
qu'est-ce qu'il faut comprendre
bien que je représente la France j'ai
aussi une culture une double culture et
c'est un peu général c'est ce n'est pas
un geste qui est négatif au contraire
c'est juste un geste déception qu'on
utilise entre amis après je peux
comprendre que à outre-mer ce soit
considéré comme un entier il y a
beaucoup de gestes que je pense
historiquement on peut utiliser dans
d'autres pays qui signifie d'autre chose
donc ce n'est pas un doigt d'honneur
absolument pas
alors il y a eu la réaction de la chef
de la délégation française avec son mari
Daniel qui a reconnu la déception mais
n'a pas insisté n'a pas parlé du geste
de la chanteuse bien sûr qu'on est
dessus il faut être honnête on a
tellement travaillé oui c'est vrai que
cette 16e place est inexplicable mais
soyons fiers de ce qu'on fait dans les
messages que j'ai reçu tout le monde est
fier de la prestation donc pour elle
cette 16e place à l'Eurovision est
inexplicable il paraît-il que c'est
chaud c'est chaud pour dans les couloirs
de France Télévisions aujourd'hui parce
que voilà tout le monde n'était pas pour
personne n'était pour lazareah
représente la France et c'est ça bien
sûr il y avait eu des débordements avant
il y avait un choix qui était contesté
au départ pour des raisons nobles ou pas
une Québécoise double culture etc on
s'interrogeait il y avait une chanson
qui prête à confusion et Cyril c'est un
fiasco franchement certains disent
aujourd'hui il aurait fallu la
disqualifier ne pas l'emmener là-bas
tout simplement mais parce que elle
avait fait des débordements refus de
répétition comportement de stars elle
n'était pas digne de représenter la
France justement elle a quitté la série
avant la fin regardez avant voilà
avant l'annonce du gagnant elle s'est
barrée
un minimum de 170 points pour gagner
hein c'est un minimum
très personnel un choix très personnel
apparemment d'Alexandra red qui a
vraiment voulu cette sur deux là tout le
monde l'a mis en garde elle est
ingérable ça va être extrêmement
compliqué etc et elle a imposé son choix
en vaincre auteur c'est courageux ça
aurait fonctionné alors égayé mais là
pour le coup la faute je reviens la
chanson est bien ou pas bien en fait le
problème
c'est quand même une corporation c'est
avant tu fais pas la promotion que tu
joues pas le jeu tous les pays vont pas
voter pour toi donc tu prends un risque
tu mets en deux mais si bien sûr
que la chanson est sympa malheureusement
elle a pas eu les points escomptés mais
c'était un très beau saboter
là c'est vrai que faire le tour on s'en
fout parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est les
points du public qui est déçu par la
prestation justement parce que alors moi
je la trouve incroyable j'adore la
chanson je trouve qu'elle est très très
efficace mais alors elle est sur une
sorte de de comme ça de podium comme ça
elle est complètement bloquée tous ceux
qui sont allés très très loin avec quand
même des chorégraphies avec des je sais
pas des danseurs à côté voilà voilà de
Barbara pravi arrivée deuxième elle
bouge pas comme ça derrière son micro
elle bouge pas et de toute façon même si
elle avait été au sol elle aurait pas
bougé parce que c'est pas sensible
le truc c'est que pourquoi elle a été
choisi d'habitude c'est vrai qu'il sert
un vote etc là
la patronne de la délégation Alexandra
et Damien là imposé ben voilà ce sera la
Zara et personne d'autre et sachez que
Sébastien Farron c'est l'ancien produit
du docteur de la Zara il nous raconte
d'abord sa rencontre avec l'artiste et
les premières collaborations et c'est
vrai que voilà très vite il dit que la
chanteuse avait des premiers caprices de
star il y a d'ailleurs eu rupture de
contrat donc c'est vrai que voilà il y a
plein de gens qui l'ont mis en garde qui
ont dit attention ça va être compliqué
etc etc moi j'aime les gens qui ont du
caractère donc franchement je l'ai
défendu jusqu'à samedi je l'ai défendu
parce que voilà j'aime bien les gens qui
ont du caractère mais écoutez ce qu'il
dit sur le la rupture de contrat
de signer un contrat chez Universal
Canada on s'est plutôt super bien
entendu au téléphone et tout j'ai
débarqué à Montréal le lendemain pour
l'avoir et la rencontre a été assez
intéressante en ami un an et demi pour
faire l'album de la Zara qui a été assez
épique parce qu'effectivement elle est
très exigeante elle est des gros
problèmes de confiance en elle etc etc
donc c'était assez compliqué d'arriver
au bout des chansons
globalement mais on était assez content
du projet final et d'ailleurs le premier
single à travers alors elle aurait un
caractère une personnalité très
compliqué et des demandes extravagantes
écoutez ce qu'il dit
en revanche elle est effectivement très
exigeante et elle a parfois des façons
de se comporter un peu un peu un peu
borderline mais de me dire elle nous est
tout le temps qu'elle voulait que
j'achète un sac Chanel et ça que
j'achète un sac Chanel si moi je suis
tombé
je suis pas ni ton producteur ni ton
amant donc il y a un moment je travaille
pour toi c'est pas moi qui vais
t'acheter ça qui c'est le demander
beaucoup elle voulait rencontrer patron
de l'Universal tous les deux jours elle
voulait avoir le sentiment qu'elle était
là la numéro 1 des priorités à venir
elle était mais en tout cas c'était pas
inintéressant du tout de travailler avec
elle voilà c'est une personnalité après
c'est vrai que voilà après je vois je
vous dis la vérité c'est que moi pour
moi c'est une star c'est une énorme
personnalité elle a un talent non mais
elle a un talent mais c'est pas c'est
pas c'est pas la bonne personne pour
l'Eurovision voilà je pense voilà je
sais pas ce que tu en penses Marie et
que toi qui connaît bien le truc
l'Eurovision moi mon Eurovision à moi il
y a 46 ans
je n'ai pas bougé du tout non plus
c'était vraiment très sage
mais mais oui aujourd'hui l'Eurovision
c'est beaucoup plus de
c'est scénographie
à l'Eurovision qui a envie qu'il soit
pas capricieux et tout ça voilà elle
elle est belle
mais c'est vrai que voilà alors il est
venu il est revenu sur le geste de la
lazareah à l'Eurovision ce fameux toz
puisque il y avait doigt d'honneur plus
tôt c'était ce qu'on appelle une double
autoroute
je pense et je pense une certaine
manière de d'avoir absolument pas
confiance en elle qu'elle traduit par
des éruptions volcaniques qu'on choisit
de représenter la France et qu'on
choisit de représenter un pays où on
fait pas un geste comme ça à la fin je
dirais
d'ailleurs je sais pas à quoi correspond
exactement le geste est-ce que c'est
contre la France contre l'Eurovision
contre le gagnant contre contre le
public
on garde quand même une espèce de
respectabilité alors avec mes équipes
nous avons eu un coup de cœur et je
crois que ça a été réciproque
aujourd'hui je peux dire quel est mon
âme sœur c'est alexandray Daniel la la
la la la la la chef de la délégation
française qui dit ça et pourtant selon
approche de la production elle avait
averti et on lui avait dit de ne pas la
prendre elle avait été prévenue de son
côté ingérable souffre un proche de la
production il y avait une possibilité de
prendre une chanson de Slimane mais
alexandra a préféré la Zara il faut
clarifier le mode de sélection qui ne
peut pas changer chaque année un coup le
choix du public un coup de choix de la
délégation c'est beaucoup trop mise en
avant cette année c'est vrai que ça ça
risque de leur coûter cher bien sûr sauf
si vraiment Cyril on l'a mise là pour
perdre pour faire un fiasco ça aussi
voilà c'est la thèse
du fiasco annoncé au moins gagnera pas
on s'en débarrasse et c'est fini il y a
ces tests qui parcourent aussi les
couloirs et c'est peut-être ça elle
s'est dit au moins avec elle on gagnera
pas donc on verra pas l'année prochaine
pour perdre s'ils font croire à des gens
parce que ça coûte de l'argent d'aller
là-bas quand même mine de rien donc faut
arrêter de faire croire oui mais alors
arrêtons d'y aller on y va plus c'est
facile de dire lazareah moi de la
semaine dernière ils ont sur toutes les
radios et même là j'entends la Zara
allez moi je m'en fous de l'Eurovision
mais j'entends partout la Zara elle est
formidable elle est formidable et ce
matin j'entends partout c'est une
calamité c'est pas chanter rime à rien
elle a fait 16e elle a fait 16e c'est
pas grave on passe à autre chose
quand tu la vends en live c'est pas la
même voix c'est pas le même coffre tu la
vois en live elle est vulgaire à souhait
je veux dire on a le droit de changer
d'avis aussi
de la faire chanter dans une cuisine
avant de l'emmener là-bas
[Rires]
c'est pas chanter vous en rendre compte
avant
on a dit qu'elle était partie avant la
Twitter l'a mis non hier j'ai été faire
pipi et je suis revenu m'asseoir à ma
place on se calme le petit voilà donc
je suis peut-être la seule mais en fait
je me dis qu'une diva une rebelle
pourquoi pas on a besoin de personnalité
je trouve ça bien mais qu'elle aille au
bout c'est à dire ces deux excuses
vaseuses elle avait envie de faire pipi
donc elle est la seule sur toutes les
délégations qui est obligé de sortir
faire pipi je suis désolé un peu pour
des jambons l'autre excuse aussi bah
j'aurais adoré qu'elle dise bah ouais
j'en ai regardé
j'y croyais vous m'avez déçu j'ai fait
un cadeau quoi
je trouve ça alors voilà bon là en tout
cas ça a été un fiasco 16e Marie
non c'est pas un fiascool
je pense que l'Eurovision c'est
compliqué il y a beaucoup de pays et
puis et puis c'est vrai alors il y a le
note les notes du jury qui sont beaucoup
plus juste parce que ce sont des
professionnels de chaque pays qui toi le
public maintenant compte trop tu trouves
la première partie et puis le note du
les notes du public ça part un peu tous
les sens tu trouves souvent normalement
devait gagner en fait la Finlande a
gagné a eu beaucoup beaucoup plus de
points du public que la Suède mais la
Suède a eu des points du juriste qui lui
a permis
et c'est ça il a fondu
il a gagné génial c'est que l'année
prochaine donc ça va être organisé en
Suède et c'est les 50 ans de waterload
là-bas donc ça va être une fête
incroyable
pour l'instant il y avait notre ami
Stéphane Bern qui qui animait enfin qui
qui commentait il a pas pu s'empêcher de
partir dans des tirades historiques
samedi soir seul problème parfois moi je
je j'ai l'impression que c'était les
histoires de Castaldi regardez
est-ce que vous savez Laurence pourquoi
et bien le comment est né l'Eurovision
et bien vous savez qu'en 1953 la maman
de Charles III était couronnée et et
pour cela et bien on a créé le réseau
Eurovision c'est drôle ça y est une
semaine exactement et il se trouve qu'il
y a une semaine on a couronné Charles
III et frère
[Rires]
je me rappelle qu'on faisait des 5
millions et demi un des 5 millions 8 à
l'Eurovision Marie pourquoi tu te
représente pas pourquoi tu refais pas
L'oiseau et l'enfant je suis sûr qu'on
regagne non c'est rigoler
non je me représenterai je ferai pas
comme Lorie non certainement pas tu as
déjà demandé tu as déjà demandé pardon
tu as déjà demandé de représenter la
France oui bien sûr je te jure que moi
je t'aurais demandé moi
fais le mari en moins qu'on gagne on
regarde non non pas du tout non
cette photo c'est pardon cette photo
c'est horrible parce que les choristes
avaient pas les bonnes robes elle ils
ont oublié les dessous et en vérité le
jour de l'Eurovision les robes sont
noirs et donc du coup on les voit un peu
à poils
père Castaldi là-bas merci merci Marie
d'avoir été avec nous merci à vous de
toutes les matières